-Thank you so much
for coming back to the show.
It is so great to see you.
-It is my pleasure.
-Thank you, thank you,
thank you.
-Late night is back!
-It's back! We're finally back!
Yes. It's been -- I've been
missing it, but thank you.
This means a lot to me.
The last time I saw you --
I don't know if you remember
this, but I have to bring it up.
-I do.
-Your daughter was on our show.
-Yeah.
-Maya was performing,
and she sang.
And you were just here
as just a supportive mom,
and it was so cool.
-Sneaking around in the back.
-Yeah. And you were backstage
and just rooting her on.
-Dancing.
-I loved it. But that is so --
I just loved that --
'Cause I didn't get a chance
to say like, "Oh, by the way,
your mom, Uma Thurman,
was here rooting you on."
I didn't want
to make a big deal.
-No, she wouldn't
have liked that.
-She wouldn't. Yeah.
But I love that you did that
backstage.
And it was so charming
and very, very --
And you also had
your younger daughter.
-Yeah.
My little one was with us.
-Luna?
-It was a family affair.
-Yeah. How old is, uh --
-Luna's 11.
-She's 11.
Alright. I have
a 10- and an 8-year-old.
-I know.
-Yeah. So they're getting older.
-Yeah, I know.
Enjoy every minute of it.
-Yeah.
-Enjoy it.
-It just happens. Right?
It just -- Yeah.
I'm getting to that
kind of years of like,
"Dad, I wonder --
Like, what's a crush?
I want to have a crush
on somebody." I'm like...
-Yeah, you've got
very little time left,
I'm afraid to warn you.
-I do, right?
-Very little time left.
-I know, okay? I'm loving it.
-Soak it up.
-I'm loving every single second.
-This Christmas has to be
the best time of your life.
-Yeah. Oh, my God. Yeah, it is.
She always keeps saying --
-It will be, too.
-She goes,
"When did you have
your first crush, Dad?"
I go, "What grade are you
in again? Fifth grade?"
I go, "I had mine in sixth."
-Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
-And then next year
when she asks me,
I'm gonna say,
"I had mine in seventh."
Yeah. Just keep
pushing it forward.
-Just keep pushing it. You can
always put braces on them
even if they don't need them.
-Yeah. Just give it...
-Just give them braces.
-You're having braces.
-Full metal head.
-That is great advice.
That is absolutely --
This is great advice.
-Just say to the doctor,
"I know it looks fine.
Can you put, like,
some headgear on her?"
-Yeah. Exactly.
I want to talk about this
because -- Room to Grow.
You've been with them...
-Since the beginning, yeah.
-25 years?
-It's an incredible story.
It was actually Maya
I was pregnant with,
who's now 25.
-Wow.
-And I lived in this brownstone
in Greenwich Village.
And I had one neighbor,
this lovely, beautiful
young woman who was my age.
And I was pregnant and, like,
getting all nervous
about it and like,
"How do I get ready
for this baby?
What am I gonna do
and what would I need?"
And then in the hallway,
there kept being
all this baby stuff piling up.
And I was watching my neighbor,
and she's very slender.
-Yeah.
-And I was becoming ginormous.
And I was like, "What's going on
with my neighbor?"
So finally I asked her...
-"When are you due?"
-I said, "What are you doing
with all this baby stuff?"
And she said, "I've got to
talk to you about it."
It's a serious, serious problem
in our community.
There are no resources
for pregnant women
and babies, 0 to 3,
in our community,
and it is the most crucial time
of a child's life.
80% --
Babies are amazing, right?
80% of the human brain
is developing in the first
three years of life.
So how we treat families,
parents, and babies
in that crucial window
really affects
the rest of their life.
-Yeah, and if you don't have
anything, then it's...
-It's just the duress.
Yeah. There's nutrition.
There's all the baby essentials
that you need.
I mean, it's crazy.
And also Room to Grow
does, like, this
comprehensive wraparound
where, every quarter, the family
goes to see a social worker
and they get to ask
all the questions
that you need to ask as you're
developing, baby is developing.
-Yeah, and coming back
into the workforce
and getting all that stuff.
-If you can. And job --
And finding
other resources for job training
and childcare.
And housing issues
are a huge issue for people.
-It is such a great thing
what you're doing.
But just -- I just want to
show some of the things that --
This is what a mother will get
on the --
This is just the first year.
-Yeah.
-They will get
some of these things.
That's just --
-And you need all those things.
-That's just the first year.
I mean, it's so helpful.
It's so helpful.
And is it just New York
or is it...?
-We are in Boston now.
-Hey.
-And it is my dream
to see this organization
be in every city where
there is need and a community
that wants a good tool
to support their community.
-Let's have it keep growing.
-Yeah.
-I want to talk
about this, too.
This is the giant awesome
fun bag.
This is
the Donate By Mail program.
Okay?
-Yeah.
-And so can you explain
what this is and
where do you get this?
-Okay, so, since we see
the family every quarter --
and as we all know,
babies change radically
like every few months
and you need new stuff,
so you barely use the stuff
that you had
before you need new stuff.
-Yeah.
-So it's really lightly used.
So a family with a baby --
95% of our things
are recycled, upcycled.
So a family with a baby
just packs up the stuff
they don't need anymore
when they're getting their new
stuff, put it in the bag,
and it gets shipped
back to Room to Grow.
-Yeah. If you go
to roomtogrow.org,
you get the bag.
I think the bag is $15.
-It's a commitment of $15.
-$15.
You get the bag sent to you.
-And then it's shipped back.
-And then it already has the
shipping label and everything,
so all you have to do
is fill it with stuff
that you want to donate,
so if you have anything --
Books Like you said --
-Books are really important.
English language.
Spanish language.
Very important also.
Socks, gloves, winter coats,
all the things that you need.
-All that stuff.
And I always bring this up
every single time,
but I remember
when you first had Maya.
-Yeah.
-And you told me, like,
"Jimmy, if you're
lucky enough to have kids,
you have to read to them."
-Yes.
-And you were reading
"Ferdinand," by the way,
to Maya.
-I was reading "Ferdinand."
You do have to read
to your children.
And that's another
crucial thing.
That kind of intervention --
giving a family the right books
to read to their child.
-Yeah.
-Like, if you don't have
that book, how can you
do that for your child?
-Yeah. This is great.
Roomtogrow.org, everybody.
Thank you so much
for coming on.
-I love you.
-And you know you're the best.
Uma Thurman, everybody!
Room to Grow's
25th Anniversary Gala
is October 25th
at the Ziegfeld Ballroom
in New York City.
Lil Rel Howery joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody!